ted has become a cultural phenomenon
through its mission of sharing big ideas
it's posted TED Talks online for free
since 2006 they feature speakers from
almost every discipline that videos are
viewed more than 3.4 billion times a
year here are some of the most popular
ones many highly talented brilliant
creative people think they're not
because the thing they were good at at
school wasn't valued or what's actually
stigmatized and I think we can't afford
to go on that way get your testosterone
up get your cortisol down don't leave
that situation feeling like oh I didn't
show them Who I am
leave that situation feel like I really
feel like I got to say Who I am and show
Who I am
the consequence of the single story is
this it robs people of dignity it makes
our recognition of a Equality man it's
difficult if emphasizes how we are
different rather than how we are similar
it was a year-long street fight it was a
slugfest vulnerability pushed I push
back I lost the fight but probably won
my life back Ted just launched a new
podcast featuring in-depth interviews
with past speakers the Ted interview is
hosted by Chris Anderson who runs the
nonprofit good morning Chris good
morning so why a podcast well a podcast
is a conversation and it can run longer
much longer you know a typical TED talk
is 18 minutes or less podcasts can be as
long as you like these run about an hour
which means you've got a chance to go
much deeper into a speaker's thinking
the TED talk is meant to be just the
beginning of an idea hey here's
something really interesting this is the
chance to really understand their
thinking more deeply but you know - you
know Chris when I first heard it I
thought who thinks this is a good idea
I've already listened to the podcast why
do I now want to listen to an interview
with a person who just did the podcast
and then I listened to Elizabeth Gilbert
and I went whoa you do the interview and
it's really really good you started with
her why because she's amazing she's
extraordinary you know she gave a TED
talk about this slightly strange idea at
first glance that about what what is
genius what is creative genius and most
people think of that as a what you have
creative genius is
she says no no crater genus is something
that comes to you from outside so it was
a kind of inspiring talk and it gives
you a picture for how to think
creativity but what does she actually
mean by that so we started talking about
that and her kind of magical view of the
world am i slightly more skeptical
pushback on that but then we ended up in
a conversation about grief which was she
just lost her partner she lost her
partner it was the first time she'd
really talked at length publicly about
it and I have to say just sitting there
we were in my home and I was just
overcome with how extraordinary her
response to that was she was so eloquent
and she really you know she really
helped me a lot as well as I keep
thinking about things that get our
attraction as opposed to things that
need our attention and in this era of
what are we now 140 characters on
Twitter has it been example scroll
through for headlines and click click
bait but there is a desire for
understanding and longer formats
yeah that's it's the tragedy of the era
we're in right now is that all of our
attention is being focused on these
short hits and we're succeeding and
making each other really angry but we're
not succeeding in actually communicating
with each other very well because when
you're understanding you're listening
yeah when you're in two tribes fighting
each other or you know that that is not
a recipe for learning anything so yeah
the notion that behind all this mess
they're actually ideas out there there
are people thinking dreaming offering
really beautiful things to say if you
just take the time slow down take the
time to listen to them and go where
curiosity takes you that can be such a
fantastic antidote to all the sort of
hate and that we're in right now and the
topics and the speakers really run the
gamut what makes for a great TED talk is
it the topic or is it the speaker what's
more important it has to be both you the
speakers who are great performers but
have nothing to say that's no good at
all we can't stand that so it has to be
someone who really has an interesting
idea or an interesting event or
interesting work that they want to
communicate and then they just have to
find a way of communicating it
authentically the thing about TED talks
is that
people put a huge amount of preparation
into how to really crystallize what they
must care about and to show why it
matters and obviously they have
enthusiasm and joy for what is that what
you're gonna try to put at the heart of
the podcast I mean it's you obviously
can't just be like the TED talk so
what's at the heart of the conversation
in the podcast it's it's their idea
they're thinking you know just trying to
go deeper my ideas aren't little things
that land neatly that you can package
they usually you know they start a
conversation they they are open to
criticism they can take you in lots of
different directions different people
can react to them in different ways and
so it's kind of trying to dance all the
way around their thinking and and let a
chance give people a chance just to
understand it better that much more
better interacting the idea not just
received as you say the TED talks have
made you more hopeful about the world I
get that because you you take on topics
that you think I might not be interested
in but the people are so good in the
stories telling is so great
one nice things happening in this world
there are nice things I mean they
sometimes give me a lot as well I mean
work this very fragile time right now
whether it's more to be worried about
than ever but also more amazingness
going on behind the scenes than ever and
the amazingness part isn't talked about
enough thank you chris is a great idea
yeah I read all of us